congrats on nobody
i had a [ __ ] blast with it bob kicked
so much ass
i'm gonna be stunned if you guys aren't
making a sequel um it's
it's so good um and that's it we're done
click right exactly i'm curious when
you're writing a script like this which
is going to have action sequences in it
in the script are you saying like
there's an awesome bus fight in this
movie in the script are you writing
amazing buzz
fight or how does that sort of work in
the script
of like in the writing when you're
inserting action set pieces
uh i write i write a great deal of
action uh i grew up
loving action movies i write what i
watch or i love and you know the best is
when you go back to you know
sam hong and jet li and you know the the
street fighter with
uh you know oh i just i love that kind
of stuff so
i i tend to overwrite action a bit and
yet
um when you hang out with a stunt team
and you get to geek out about what's on
the page and what they do with it
it's rarely the same but every now and
then uh there's always
one thing that was in the script that
they're like that's [ __ ] cool and
they break it in and you're like oh that
thing made it
you know um but honestly in nobody it
was such
it was such a long pre-production and a
swift production
that the third act uh sequence that
siege
that was on the page was like uh
we'll get to that like so when you saw
you know a lot of those elements
dude that is everyone else and i giggled
you know uh that is that's that's
odenkirk that's ilya that's braden
that's mark that's kelly that's david it
means
everyone involved in that process and
you're like uh dude and they did it well
yeah what's crazy is i think ilya told
me that they shot that whole thing in
one day
oh my gosh you know and one of
what i loved about you know david and
ilya
is you know dave really took it under
his wing and
you know sometimes it's tough when one
of the producers on the set
is a director himself and yet you know
he was there to teach and learn at the
same time
and near the end when they had no more
money or time
david grabbed a camera you know and he
did pickups and he was helping out
and i mean not saying that you don't
have to do that but god damn that's cool
like when you see a guy who's like i'm
producing this and hey can i grab you a
sandwich that kind of thing
um i loved it man i love i love that
that thing at the end of it
throughout was still that kind of what
do you need this is a this is a student
film with a little bit more money
yeah it's definitely a little bit more
money but you don't say it
but i mean it's a it's a 15 million
dollar movie which you know
completely and the thing is that like uh
listen you guys shot the thing in 34
days
um which is not a lot of time to make a
movie that has
action set pieces like this yeah one you
know that
that's a credit to uh you know 80 87 11
of all 87 north
and daniel bernhard who who for years uh
trained uh
bob you know for free on his own time
and they became friends and he
his energy on set and you know his death
on the bus
not not his death on the bus but like
him getting his ass kicked it was kind
of like the
the cherry on top of everything um and
to that point man
that's bob for the most part outside of
two scenes uh where you you know
technically for
insurance reasons you have to have a
stunt double that's bob man
oh yeah no and by the way him training
for the two years absolutely makes this
movie and
i think that that you know you don't
have to cut away or try to cheat it you
can tell
when you're watching it that's bob try
doing this and throwing punches and
you know all that stuff but um a lot of
people
online will say or a lot of people have
said it's
you know and even i've sort of said it's
bob odekirk's john wick and i don't mean
that in a bad way
i just mean that it's kind of is john
wick so what's your reaction to that do
you
do you like that that comparison or you
sort of like it's completely wrong
i [ __ ] love that comparison man i
mean these are the movies i grew up with
in love
i'm not here to reinvent the wheel i'm
here to make a really good wheel and
you're like i want to [ __ ] ride on
that wheel
and so when you look at the the world
building of it all like the
delete the weapons the bond the the you
know the statham all that kind of stuff
stuff i grew up with jason bourne
all those elements are there because i'm
[ __ ] playing on the playground in the
pl
in the sandbox and those are the toys at
my disposal so the idea that in ronin
you allude to a world beneath the world
without seeing it sometimes we we just
hear about it other times we get to see
it
dude all of those things if every movie
i do after this point
people enjoy and they're like but it's
like john wick i'll be like [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
got it when you are obviously if this is
a hit
everyone wants to make a sequel after
your success with john wick
because obviously the first one you had
no idea what it was going to become
and you're sort of like you know with
the sequels you have to sort of or you
had to sort
of build the world while also making it
fit with what you've already done
how much in nobody were you in the
writing process
thinking okay let me make sure i have
like a bible
and a backstory and it's sort of like
the subject like the
subterranean world figured out prior to
making this or while writing yeah uh
none
honestly a bunch of notebooks with some
doodles
i mean it kind of goes back to the first
john wick
and even on when i visit the production
on nobody is
on first java keanu looked at me at a
certain point he's like do you got more
of these in your head by the way i can't
do a piano
so i'm going to try and i was like yeah
and he's like where would you go i was
like i got i got seven of them
you know and what i like looking at him
is very
kind of the minute proportions of things
i'm not a saving private ryan guy
i love that movie that's not the movie
i'm going to make i'm going to make hell
is for heroes
you know i'm not gonna make the exorcist
but i'm gonna make cabin in the woods
you know when you think of like i love
these things but you kind of know the
lane
you're in so with nobody you got a
couple of hints
and ilya would offer a hint or i would
offer a hint
and we'd ask the other what does that
mean and we're kind of like don't
[ __ ] know we'll figure it out when we
get there you know
um well to me uh the i don't want to get
into spoilers because i'll i might run
this before it comes out
but um the ending of the movie you know
sets up maybe something that could
happen in the future um
how much because look the movie's really
good how much are you
already starting like jotting down
sequel ideas and how much have you sort
of talked about that
and or are you like superstitious about
doing anything until it comes
oh no no i mean i'm one of those guys
that you're right i have like
50 things going on but every night for
at least an hour i spec i open up a
empty document and i doodle you know
because i [ __ ] love this man
and when it comes to no i'm sorry for
the cursing i get nervous
i think listen you're you're that's the
way i get when i get super excited about
right
and like start pursing and i've tried
i've gotten in trouble for it
and i try to cut down on it but every
once in a while it slips through
because grandpa and grandpa and aunts
and uncles see this like we really liked
your interview but man derek
yeah i know um but here's the thing with
nobody like
remember that the first scene in the
movie uh that is the first thing i ever
pitched bob
in the in the in the meeting because i
had the dream the night before
and i told sonia my wife before the
meeting she said you gotta open with
that
i pitched that and bob's like you're
[ __ ] hired right and so
on the second one i have the opening
scene and we all just
chuckle and cackle when you see this
thing because it's it's it's in line
with that
and i always want to begin that way you
know i love the old roger bond movies
uh bond movie roger moore bond movies
because they began with the last
sequence of events in a movie that
didn't exist
i want to just do a snapshot of that and
you're in
so when you think about where this could
go in the future look i have massive
respects for these tentpole
franchises do i want to do so on them am
i doing some of them yes
but honestly i don't want the next movie
to be all that much bigger
i want the action to emulate the raid
old boy
you know the the elevator sequence in
die hard with a vengeance the the
elevator sequence in in captain america
uh in the winter soldier like the
intimacy atomic blonde where she beats
the [ __ ] out of the guys in the car
like i want more of that for bob and
that's what bob wants he wants that
physicality itself
but the story is like what they always
say in tv it's
still true for for comic books for video
games for movies
character is key and so we got to keep
with bob and i don't want his family to
disappear
like i think they're really really
important but you also don't want to do
the mr and mrs thing
mr and mrs smith thing where everyone's
an assassin
uh we've seen that before this is bob
you know and
it's a it's a abnormal guy trying to be
normal and that's where the fun can be
had you know
you guys discussed obviously he just
started filming the final season
of better call saul have you guys sort
of talked about
hey if this thing takes off like what
are you doing right after your rap
oh yeah no i mean that it's funny
because
when you look at the size of this movie
compared to everything else on universal
slate
it's tiny but the the love for it
even before that first trailer and with
the trailer and
and blessedly now with the reviews i i
can't wait but like uh you know i'm
doing
i'm doing a television show with bob
that he he's co-creating with me and
he's producing
and then uh you know we're we're doing
another movie together
um outside of um uh
nobody as well that it that kind of
plays in the same but similar landscape
and uh dude here's the thing about bob
you know how you see an interview with
someone
like uh like i'm doing stuff with like
patton oswalt and sterling k brown
you're like i think he's a really nice
guy
dude he's your dad he's your favorite
uncle he's that friend of your dad's
that you're like come over all the time
i love you
and the more i get to do with him the
better i am as a person man so
i love it oh yeah no i i got to
interview him for nobody
and uh he's awesome he's also just a
huge fan
because i'm sure you're a better call
saul fan oh yeah do you try to avoid
spoilers or do you secretly like hey man
so how's the first script no i
i actively avoid them a bit because
there is uh
like for myself and falcon winter
soldier there's kind of like this
titanium
uh you know gate in place of like you
can kind of talk
you know and with him it's always been
like we geek out over the the [ __ ] we do
like
here here he's an accomplished guy and
one of the things that i love is the
number of times
that on a zoom or a call or a meeting
he'll pause and look at me and go
can you believe we get to do this for a
living and i'm like
yes you know i hope i have that energy
and i still do we're like
dude derek you know it'd be great and
then he'd pitch a scene and
he'd be like uh maybe not and i'm across
the table from going
yes you know so the energy there that
the the stuff
he does uh the more i can the more we
can all see of him the back